so let's bring in Mark ton he's been
digging into exactly what's going on
here on Capitol Hill Chief former Chief
White House speech writer for President
George W bush now an American Enterprise
Institute senior fellow and a Fox News
contributor of course Mark good to have
you back today you laid this out um with
very clearly so in terms of how hard it
is because I mean feel like we've
looking for an immigration solution my
whole life so what's the dynamic right
now with Ukraine Israel and a border
some sort of Border fix in this hundred
billion dollar
deal well first of all good for the GOP
for insisting on a border fix uh in
exchange for the Ukraine Aid it would be
good for the American people it would be
good for President Biden politically and
it would be good for Ukraine um because
the reality is this is the worst border
crisis we've ever had in American
history Jay Johnson said in 20 in 2019
that a thousand encounters at the border
would overwhelm the system we had just
had 12,000 last week uh this is a crisis
that that has to be stopped the Biden
Administration has not been doing it and
so they have to be forced to do it um
and so that's what Republicans are doing
is they're making the president do this
this will be good for him politically
imagine for for Biden's reelection
prospects if next year at this time uh
or I get before the election uh we're
back down to the average under Trump and
Obama and and his and his predecessors
instead of having 12,000 a year the The
Wall Street Journal poll showed the
other day that this is the second most
important issue to Americans after after
inflation and they disapprove by a
margin of 64 to 27 so this would help
him politically to get this done it
would um he he would have to get past
the debate question which would be to
play this sound bite from the last
debate in the last round again and say
what happened watch this I would in fact
make sure that there is we immediately
surge to the Border all those people are
seeking Asylum they deserve to be heard
that's who we are we're a nation says if
you want to flee and you're fleeing
oppression you should come so that
worked
Mark yeah I mean it he got what he asked
for but but even Democrats are turning I
mean you've got the mayor of New York
coming up to washhington pleading for
help you've got the mayor of new uh the
the the uh uh governor of New York
saying that this is a crisis we got to
stop these people coming John fedman
said we've got this is astonishing we've
got this population of City of
Pittsburgh coming every month into this
country so even Democrats are
recognizing that this is a problem but
it's also the thing is that they need to
understand this is good for Ukraine and
let me tell you why because the most
powerful argument that the anti- Ukraine
Republicans make is Joe Biden cares more
about Ukraine's borders than our own and
so the reason that's powerful is because
it's been true he has cared more about
Ukraine's borders than IR now we're a
superpower we can secure our border and
also lead in the lead on the world but
Joe Biden now gets a chance to prove
either they right or they're wrong um
either he's going to have an agreement
that tighten the border and he can say
no that's not true or he's going to
prove them right by refusing and putting
Ukraine Aid in Jeopardy as a result mark
Jon always good to see you mark thank
you very much I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis